welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Voss in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Joker and Star Wars have so many
pressing questions to break down but
there is a deeper issue that we have
been keeping from you guys that we just
don't want to hide any longer so as
always I am shouting at you from what we
have been affectionately referring to as
the blue dungeon but here's what you
might not know a month ago new rock
stars was kicked out of our old office
space now we didn't do anything wrong
other than occasionally most dangerous
lightsaber swordplay sessions in there
but our landlord knocked on our office
door and was like hey you got ten days I
got a new tenant who's willing to pay
more so sorry so we packed and we moved
this is technically the same blue
dungeon but it is somewhere new we David
Copperfield at it to a temporary space
that I don't really want to tell you
about I'm a bit embarrassed just know it
might or might not be a zoomed-in side
of a porta potty but we have decided to
use this turning point as an opportunity
to grow so we are currently in the
process of building new sets for even
more of what you guys want from our
channel and literally every day for the
past month we've been trying to get to a
point where this blue dungeon has a new
permanent home but a home that's more
than the YouTube channel it's always
been a brave new venture that we are
calling new rockstars Digital Studios
and our DES because yeah when it comes
to this stuff we love there's no shame
in being one of the Nerds anymore like
what's the sense of being a casual fan
of anything it's okay to care so our
hope for n RDS is a network of content
that includes everything we're currently
doing but more even deeper breakdowns
breakdowns of stuff that you've been
begging us to do podcasts with expert
guests theory videos with insane levels
of research like we want to go
Mythbusters but also new shows new
channels and maybe some new shirts for
me seriously I got like four we're so
eager to get moving on this but we're a
real small crew when it comes to people
who are in the office every day there's
really just like four or five of us now
many of you have come to us asking how
you can help this channel other than
watching liking sharing and subscribing
of which we are so grateful for it but
now for those of you who are able to
spare just a bit of generosity you can
help build new rockstars a new
home-free me out of this blue dungeon
and release me into a blue dungeon that
doesn't smell as bad but also some new
spaces for me to do my thing throughout
the week with more nerdy friends new and
old you can help with all of this by
becoming an official new rockstars
patreon so here's what we'll do with
your support first we're gonna keep the
same daily breakdowns and Theory videos
rolling out without any interruptions or
paywalls for everyone for free none of
that's changed but in addition we are
gonna offer deeper ways to be part of
this team because here's the deal folks
we are entering a golden age of nerdy
content streaming services like Disney
Plus Apple TV plus HBO Mac's Amazon
they're soon going to fill our lives
with weekly episodes of series with film
level production value and rich layers
of detail we want to break down all of
it and expand from just these nerdy
properties dupe genres like horror
sci-fi animated series gaming content
and that's not all we are gonna launch a
weekly Q&A show so that we can answer
your biggest nerdy questions directly
all the Marvel news and theory
explainers that we make we want to go
even deeper with those Limbrick and
Morty's fourth season comes out next
month there are some plans in the works
to partner with starburns to host the
official Rick and Morty after-show
featuring special guests from the show
and other superfans and in preparation
for a star wars episode 9 we plan to
launch a weekly re-watch series breaking
down all the missable details from every
film in the saga and on top of that we'd
love to break down other beloved films
and TV series the way that we've been
able to do for the matrix and the Nolan
Batman trilogy so my favorite videos
we've been able to do but haven't had
the time to like for example the boys on
Amazon amazing series but it's tough to
break it down on YouTube because of its
dark and violent subject matter YouTube
censors us from even talking about it so
here's the plan for patrons willing to
give just a bit more we are going to
offer an exclusive premium breakdown
once a month voted on by the patrons
where we don't want to play YouTube's
game we can be completely independent
and uncensored the way normal human
beings and nerds talk about this we love
we're also gonna offer patrons early
access to our normal content as often as
we can so that you can have a head start
in those first comments you first stirs
you're so first thing and in addition to
reward offers like new rockstars mugs
shirts other merged really you will be
an extra valued part of this community
these are really is just a handful of
nerds here at NRD s and we want to make
this awkward transition period counts by
building something special for you guys
on the
their side of it so if you want to be
part of this and if you're able to
please come check out the details of new
rock stars Digital Studios at
patreon.com slash new rock stars because
you can make this blue dungeon one with
fewer toilet clusters
[Music]